oh hi yes the infirmary president Urich
responded to question Carolina 120 710
from Juarez Mexico so I think global
economy will be in 35 in 10 years what
can we do to make it better mama cruelly
what we make the environment that we've
had over the last 40 years one of
Western driven globalization one where
values are common among all summer
countries that that have real influence
global economic systems critical systems
as a period of unmatched efficiency and
productivity and even though there are
winners and losers nonetheless was one
that definitely a scope towards more
economic growth we're not going to see
that going for the next three five ten
years it's going to be much more
challenging but clearly there will be
relative win with you losers in part
resilience will become more important
and growth Japan has nothing to teach us
whatsoever on growth in the global
economy right now they're going towards
the third Ross decade but they have a
lot to teach us about resilience after
an extraordinary earthquake tsunami and
nuclear catastrophe Japanese society
still doing very well increasingly when
we look at the global economy even if
those numbers aren't as God even with
problems of food distribution and water
availability and climate change and
fights over over natural resources and
fights between state capitalism in a
free market that's appeared where we
will see folks looking towards safety
we'll see much more risk aversion and so
countries that can better more adaptable
and governments you would have more
resilience and stability will be the
ones we look towards that's true for
both consolidated Democratic regimes
like the United States and in Japan but
it's also true for more consolidated
authoritarian regimes and in that regard
it's notable that the Arab Spring spread
throughout a lot of the middle east's
letter not really among the wealthiest
of the Gulf state economies places that
will be relatively insulated even Russia
given the demonstrations going on hooton
may well take some of that on he may
well not but the relative stability of
that government is comparable high and
that certainly bodes better in terms of
economic stability and
over the medium term thanks very much